we got Howie Mandel on the show today
but first for a limited time post mates
is giving our listeners $100 free
delivery in their first seven days
download the app use promo code KFC and
get $100 free delivery for the first
seven days promo code KFC anything you
need anytime you need it postmates it
Howie Mandel here of America's Got
Talent on NBC and Deal or No Deal nine
o'clock Wednesday's on CNBC animals
doing things at ten o'clock on NatGeo
wild and my own first stand-up comedy
special in 20 years that is downloadable
I also have a little catering business
you can call me anytime and I'm opening
a flower shop anyway what I'm doing
right here is I'm going to answer the
Internet
here's my first question from the
internet
Thank You Internet okay if you had to
pick one person to be the ambassador for
the human race to meet aliens who would
it be I don't know that he's still alive
but Marcel Marceau like a mime don't you
think it would be great like it would be
easier to anybody who does mind when
they say take me to your leader I want
them to go what's going on here and then
explain and then you wait and then you
still explain that you know sometimes
from time to time we get trapped in a
box or it gets windy down here so we
need a rope so they'll understand this I
think that a mime would make the
communication and the understanding of
the human race so much easier than any
spokesperson go ahead you have one
free-throw shot if you make it you get 1
million dollars if you miss it you can
never text again the answer is yes I
take the shot because I think I can make
it here's the point oh you're right I
realized that questions aren't even on
cards they're on pieces why couldn't
they just be on the internet like you
say why can't I look at a laptop didn't
this come this comes from the look at
this the production value I would take a
shot and weak and I would get it because
I'm very good I I'm a good free-throw
and no I am free-throw
but that way I'd get the million dollars
and with that million dollars I'd hire
somebody to do all my texting if your TV
remote didn't work and you were too sick
to get up to change the channel
what station would you want on I like it
I like Telemundo I just like I don't
know what's going on but the ladies are
hot I have no idea what I'm watching but
I always I'll always watch if you could
have one person narrate or do a
play-by-play of you having
who would it be the person I'm having
sex with this just in it's just out
would you ever would you have a
threesome with Kelly Ripa and Regis
Philbin no no it's not a scam this one's
not escape oh they hung up on me
when a scammer hangs up on you that is
that's the villain anyway back to the
internet Oh would I like to have a
threesome with I don't think that would
be considered a threesome I mean I think
Kelly and I would be busy
I don't know that Regis at this point I
mean I think the key would just be don't
wake him stop narrating the sex Kelly
would you rather throw up every time
someone says McDonald's or where for a
fedora for the rest of your life and if
anybody asks about it you have to
sincerely say I just like the way it
looks
yes
yes is the answer I'll wear a fedora and
say or throw up every time someone says
McDonald's I like fedoras and I do think
I like the way I look no I like the way
I looking for doors in fact this is not
a joke
this season on AGT I'm gonna wear a
fedora I just asked the the the Wardrobe
lady can I wear a fedora and I can and
and she says why do you want to wear a
fedora and I said I just like the way it
looks would I rather have no friends or
no internet tell me what the difference
is if you have no internet you have no
friends right
don't people look at their Facebook and
going are me friends I have no you don't
you have pictures of people that doesn't
make them your friends I'd rather have
no fur
I don't I don't know that I have friends
will you be my friend who's ever
watching I want you to be my friend and
the kind of friend who will hand me a
card and doesn't give a [ __ ] about what
I do with it that's a friend you're not
a friend please don't fold the cards
this just in I think this is supposed to
be what I know I'm in front of a green
screen what is behind me a giant dick
just realize you got to ask before
you're on a green screen you can have
one thing free for the rest of your life
what do you choose handjobs
[Laughter]
what is that good it's with my wife but
I wish you wouldn't charge it's not I
don't go willy-nilly it's my wife what
is your stance on washing your hands
after taking a piss Oh saw that coming
didn't you this is my stance